es ist der grausam dunkle donner der
vernichtung der aus der ukraine in die
hauptstädte der welt
ein angriffskrieg angezettelt von einem
mann der ein volk und seine nation
auslöschen will ein völkermord so sehen
es viele mitten in europa ab 80 jahre
nach ende des zweiten weltkrieges
es ist ein krieg bei dem es um alles
geht um unsere zukunft darum wie wir
leben werden da sind sich die beiden
männer die wir getroffen haben ein
timothy snyder ist einer der
bedeutendsten historiker der gegenwart
er berät regierungen kaum jemand kennt
sich in osteuropa und mit den
hintergründen des krieges besser aus
es ist glaube ich nicht übertrieben zu
behaupten dass das schicksal europas als
einen zusammenschluss stabiler sicherer
demokratien weitgehend davon abhängt was
im nächsten monat passiert wenn russland
die ukraine gewaltsam einnimmt und
politische säuberungen exekutiert dann
ist das ein schlag von dem sich die
europäischen demokratien nur schwer
erholen können
ein sieg russlands in der ukraine würde
so blaupause für die konflikte und
konfrontationen des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts russland dürfe diesen krieg
auf keinen fall gewinnen meint alexander
windmann lieutenant colonel windmann war
europa direktor des nationalen
sicherheitsrates der usa bisher von
donald trump gefeuert wurde
wenn russland den krieg gewinnt dann ist
es nicht nur ein sieg für russland dann
ist es ein sieg des autoritarismus ein
sieg im interesse autoritärer staaten
dann werde europa und die usa an vielen
fronten belagert und angegriffen werden
von russland wie von china aus dem
mittleren osten lateinamerika
diese regine werden in eine starke
position versetzt können ihre interessen
voranbringen es ist eine entscheidende
schlacht
eine schlacht aber vor allem um das
überleben und die zukunft der ukraine
ukrainerinnen von völkermord spricht der
amerikanische präsident an begriff vor
dem viele europäer noch zurückschrecken
ganz besonders die deutschen
[Musik]
die aufrufe der russischen staatsmedien
sind praktisch der aufruf zum völkermord
an den ukrainern und ich denke das ist
keine extreme sichtweise wir sind noch
nicht an dem punkt an dem russland
diesen plan vollständig umsetzen kann
aber wenn russland gewinnt dann wird es
versuchen diese pläne weiter umzusetzen
den völkermord mit
bloodlands hat er das standardwerk über
die politik der vernichtung durch stalin
und hitler geschrieben bloodlands da
sind die blutgetränkten böden von
belarus polen und dem baltikum und vor
allem der ukraine
der krieg gegen die ukraine und ihre
menschen wo die ins vision von einem
gros russischen reich würde sich
anschließen an die vernichtungs
ideologie der großen menschen schlechter
hitler und stalin
der russische staat mit dem wir uns
heute zu tun haben kann man mit plateau
als tyrannei verstehen das ist ein
zustand in dem nur eine person
unkontrolliert die eigenen ideen
umsetzen kann auf niemanden mehr hören
muss und wahrscheinlich an diesem punkt
noch nicht einmal weiß wen sie überhaupt
anhören könnte
putin regiert als tyrann vor dem sich
alle fürchten auch im eigenen land im
eigenen apparat niemand können seinen
kopf hinein sehen und doch habe er nie
ein zweifel daran gelassen was er
vorhabe mal sneijder
er hat immer wieder klar und deutlich
gesagt dass er es als eine historische
mission versteht russland und die
ukraine zu vereinen
wie dieser krieg endet hat erhebliche
moralische konsequenzen es geht nicht
nur um eine seite gegen die andere wenn
die russen gewinnen bedeutet das dass
alle demokratien mit gewalt gestürzt und
das imperien im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert in europa erneut florieren
könnten wenn aber die ukraine gewinnen
bedeutet das dass demokratien zumindest
eine chance haben können seit jahren
spricht der russische präsident der
ukraine ein existenzrecht ab die ukraine
sei keine nation sie gehöre zu russland
man sollte hier klarstellen dass die
ukraine niemals die stabilen traditionen
eines echten staates aufgewiesen hat
aufgebaut vom globalen westen sei es
bevölkert und regiert von nazis deren
ziel es sei russland zu vernichten
die russische führung hat gesagt dass es
keinen ukrainischen staat und keine
ukrainischer nation gibt russische
polizisten haben eine anleitung
veröffentlicht wie man die ukrainische
nation zerstören kann und sie sagen dass
jeder der sich mit der ukraine
identifiziert entweder getötet oder in
ein konzentrationslager gebracht werden
muss
als nach dem abzug russischer truppen
von kiew anfang april klar wird mit
welch bestialischer brutalität die
russischen truppen auch gegen zivilisten
vorgegangen sind
veröffentlicht die staatliche russische
nachrichtenagentur ria novosti zur
rechtfertigung einen langen artikel den
man auch als handbuch des völkermordes
verstehen kann darin heißt es unter
anderem
die nazis die ihre waffen erheben müssen
auf dem schlachtfeld vernichtet werden
und zwar so viele wie möglich dabei darf
kein unterschied gemacht werden zwischen
der armee und den freiwilligen
territorialen verteidigungskräfte und
weiter heißt es neben den höheren rängen
gibt es jede menge einfacher bürger die
sich schuldig gemacht haben nazi
mitläufer oder nazi komplizen zu sein
die gerechte bestrafung für diesen teil
der bevölkerung kann nur sein dass sie
die ganze härte des gerechten krieges
gegen die nazis zu spüren bekommen
umerziehungslager und deportationen
werden angekündigt die zerstörung
nationaler symbole die auslöschung eines
staates
wenn du sagst es gibt keinen staat kein
volk dann bedeutet das dass du die
absicht hast dieses land auszuradieren
die menschen dort loszuwerden wenn man
kulturdenkmäler zerstört und zivilisten
tötet und wenn dies eindeutig durch eine
ent menschlichen die ideologie motiviert
ist gehen die russischen soldaten selbst
von haus zu haus und sagen wo sind die
nazis die ukraine als nazis zu
bezeichnen ist eine ent menschlichen der
hassrede die das töten der ukraine
legitimieren soll das ist es was vor
sich geht
viel zu lange hätte die welt weggesehen
putin und das russische regime
normalisiert besonders scharf geht
schneider mit deutschland ins gericht
auch wenn sich jetzt langsam etwas
bewege die noch immer zögerliche haltung
in bezug auf ein vollständiges öl und
gas embargo die lieferung von schweren
waffen und die angst vor einer
eskalation sei ein zynischer umgang mit
der geschichte der die realität nicht
wahrhaben wollen
es ist sehr bequem immer nur zu
reagieren es ist sehr bequem wenn ein
krieg startet immer nur von eskalation
zu sprechen es ist bequem weil es dir
das gefühl gibt das richtige zu tun okay
es ist eine tyrannei aber ich mag den
tyrannen und muss auf seine gefühle
rücksicht nehmen
der touran hat jetzt ein anderes land
überfallen ich mache jetzt das richtige
und sorge mich vor allem um eskalation
eskalation wird jetzt zum kern von allem
über das ich spreche und das gibt dir
dann das billige gefühl der
rechtschaffenheit dieses billige gefühl
der rechtschaffenheit erlaubt ihr dann
die gesamte europäische sicherheits
ordnung die zukunft der demokratie und
das schicksal vieler millionen ukraine
zu ignorieren
deutschlands russland politik habe über
zwei jahrzehnte auf wandel durch handel
gesetzt und wirtschaftlich davon
profitiert der preis aber massive
abhängigkeiten die den blick auf die
tatsächliche entwicklung in russland
getrübt hätten
wir haben uns etwas vorgemacht was in
russland passiert
es tut mir leid dass ich deutschland zu
sehr kritisieren aber deutsche politiker
bereits führend bei der normalisierung
russlands
sie haben russland in einer weise
beschrieben die völlig falsch ist
putin freund gerhard schröder der den
mann im kreml einmal einen lupenreinen
demokraten genannt hat sei nur das
extremste beispiel dafür wie deutsche
politiker innen und industrielle über
zwei jahrzehnten den russischen tyrannen
und seine visionen normalisiert und
hoffähig gemacht hätten
wenn man lange braucht um klar zu sehen
liegt es auch daran dass man das gefühl
hat moralisch involviert zu sein und das
trifft auf die deutschen zu
denn wenn klar wird dass russland in der
ukraine einen völkermord begeht dann
denken die deutschen na ja wir haben
jahrzehntelang gesagt dass wir gegen
völkermord sind
irgendwie haben wir nicht gemerkt dass
dieser mensch das vorhat und was noch
schlimmer ist einige unserer führenden
politiker wie gerhard schröder haben
diese personen in unserem fernsehen
ausdrücklich als demokraten gelobt und
schlimmer noch unsere eigene
energiepolitik scheint diesen krieg zu
finanzieren wenn die deutschen also so
lange brauchen um das zu begreifen dann
liegt das vielleicht daran dass man
nicht verstehen will dass man ein
gewisses maß an verantwortung dafür
trägt
viel zu lange hätten deutsche politiker
die nähe zur russischen führung gesucht
und deren interessen vertreten dass der
deutsche bundespräsident quasi zu
persona non grata in der ukraine erklärt
wurde vom ukrainischen präsidenten
zielinski ausgeladen wurde in kiew an
einem treffen der präsidenten von polen
und den baltischen staaten teilzunehmen
sei richtig und müsse man als klares
zeichen verstehen meint alexander will
[Musik]
us-präsident selensky hat nichts zu
verlieren er kämpft um das überleben
seines volkes und er muss sehr schwere
entscheidungen treffen präsident
steinmeiers bedürfnis öffentlich
unterstützung zu zeigen zurück zu weisen
war die richtige entscheidung denn
dieses öffentliche zeigen von
unterstützung hat keine konkrete
substanz ich denke es war als signal
gedacht an deutschland die deutsche
führung den kanzler und die deutschen es
ist zeit für eine seite zu entscheiden
mit seiner energiepolitik deutschland
eine mitschuld an dem russischen
vernichtungskrieg die deutsche
abhängigkeit von russischem gas vor der
die usa und die europäischen verbündeten
seit langem gebaut hätten hätten
deutschland denken und handeln gelähmt
und putin gestärkt sneijder
jetzt germany's die deutsche
energiepolitik ist meiner meinung nach
einer der großen geopolitischen fehler
des einundzwanzigsten jahrhunderts der
irakkrieg war der größte fehler die
deutsche energiepolitik ist
wahrscheinlich die nummer zwei
denn die deutschen befinden sich jetzt
in einer situation in der sie mit einem
faschistischen regime konfrontiert sind
das einen vernichtungskrieg gegen ein
anderes europäisches land führt und die
deutschen sagen wir können nicht so
handeln wie wir gerne handeln würden
wegen unserer eigenen energiepolitik
wegen unserer eigenen entscheidungen und
genau diese vorstellung dass es nun
wieder ein krieg geben könnte trägt
jetzt zum krieg bei wenn man die eigenen
entscheidungen über dinge wie
energiepolitik nicht mit machtpolitik
und tyrannei in verbindung bringt dann
lädt man zum krieg ein und ich fürchte
das ist ein teil dessen was passiert ist
deutschland habe in putins plänen schon
seit langem eine strategische bedeutung
gehabt neben der abhängigkeit von
russischem gas sei die beeinflussung der
deutschen erinnerungskultur
eines der wichtigsten ziele russische
außenpolitik gewesen
deutschland wird von russland als
machtzentrum europas betrachtet und sie
versucht die ganze deutsche macht zu
unterdrücken sie tun das indem sie auf
die deutsche erinnerungskultur
zurückgreifen sie interpretieren ganz
bewusst die deutsche erinnerungskultur
als eine art politische waffe sie wissen
dass der zweite weltkrieg die deutschen
sehr beschäftigt also arbeiten sie sehr
hart daran sicherzustellen dass die
russen das opfer des krieges sind und
nicht die ukraine und das funktioniert
dann im einklang mit deutschland als
sehr große markt für erdgas es ist ein
teufelskreis in dem deutsche politiker
zum beispiel prominente deutsche
persönlichkeiten wie gerhard schröder
die deutsche abhängigkeit von russischem
erdgas mit deutschlands schuldgefühlen
im hinblick auf den zweiten weltkrieg
assoziieren das ist eine sehr
gefährliche synthese
deutschlands umgang mit der geschichte
sei einzigartig kein anderes land hätte
sich seine vergangenheit und seiner
schuld so gestellt in der gegenwärtigen
krise aber werde sich zeigen wie ernst
es deutschland mit seiner
vergangenheitsbewältigung wirklich ist
die gesamte vergangenheitsbewältigung im
jahr 2022 ist wahrscheinlich die
wichtigste prüfung für deutschland seit
1945 haben die deutschen sie jemals
ernst gemeint ist oder nicht
wenn sich deutschland jetzt von
schnellem entschiedenem handeln abwendet
dann ist das ein zeichen dafür dass mit
dieser erinnerungskultur schon lange
etwas nicht mehr stimmt
das jahr 2022 wird zum wichtigsten
moment für die deutschen über ihre
eigene vergangenheit nachzudenken und
darüber wie diese verarbeitet wurde denn
wenn die erinnerungskultur dazu führt
dass man glaubt es gäbe eine
legitimation für imperiales gehabe in
einer kleinen demokratie
einzumarschieren dann ist etwas mit der
erinnerungskultur sehr schief gelaufen
nie wieder war das deutsche credo
staatsräson nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
jetzt werde sich zeigen ob alles nur
eine leere hülse war mein sneijder es
gebe momente in der geschichte die den
welten noch verändern in denen es keine
grauzonen mehr gäbe in denen es um sieg
oder niederlage gehe
dies ist ein krieg in dem die eine seite
die russische behauptet die andere seite
die ukraine seien kein richtiges volk in
einem solchen krieg haben sieg und
niederlage eine echte bedeutung
nach den massiven verlusten rompuy von
dem norden der ukraine zieht russland
jetzt schwere kampfverbände im osten
zusammen wir müssten damit rechnen dass
der tyrann im kreml unter allen
umständen versuchen werde bis zum 9 mai
im nationalen feiertag zum sieg über
nazi-deutschland einem brutalen
vernichtungskrieg in der ost ukraine zu
führen meint alexander winter
er muss zeigen dass es die zehntausenden
gefallenen und verwundeten russischen
soldaten die isolation russlands und die
wirtschaftlichen kosten der sanktionen
es wert waren und zu einem greifbaren
ergebnis geführt haben ein sieg auf dem
schlachtfeld der ukraine einen sieg den
er bisher nicht vorweisen kann er ist
unter druck siegreiche einheiten auf der
sieges parade marschieren zu lassen so
wie es die sowjets 1945 getan haben er
braucht dieses bild jetzt im jahr 2022
es wird eine schlacht von der sichtbar
die mir putin wie er selber klar gemacht
hat von nichts und niemanden abhalten
lassen wird in einem krieg den er der
ukraine und der welt aufgezwungen hat
eine schlacht in der es um unser aller
zukunft geht die geschlagen wird von den
ukrainern europa inneren
leider gibt es kein anderes mittel als
den krieg selbst um diesen krieg zu
führen wir können sagen dass auch
sanktionen relevant sind und natürlich
sollte deutschland in diesem moment der
geschichte kein russisches gas kaufen in
30 jahren werden unsere kinder und
enkelkinder fragen warum das nicht
schneller geschehen ist andere dinge
haben bedeutung aber dieser krieg kann
nur auf dem schlachtfeld gewonnen werden
schneider ist der festen überzeugung
dass sich deutschland entscheiden muss
auf welcher seite der geschichte stehen
will und ob es bereit sei dafür alles
notwendige zu tun